I'm so sorry I was so embarrassed I was
gonna apologize to you also we weren't
great we were not I'm sorry
it's the Laguna Beach reunion we've all
been waiting for Lauren Conrad and her
reality TV Nemesis Kristin Cavallari
Elsie joined Kristen and a mutual ex
Stephen Coletti on their back to the
beach podcast 16 years after the hit MTV
reality series wrapped this is not the
time to rock The Love Boat unless you
know that it's the right time to end a
relationship
okay Lauren's like
yeah back in the day Lauren and Kristen
made for great reality TV and now Lauren
is back with our former co-stars and
dishing on all things Laguna which she
just re-watched for the first time
watching it was like so much worse than
I had imagined it would be really it was
really cringy part of the cringe Factor
all that drama between Lauren and
Kristen which they say was played up for
the cameras my take on it is you and I
never really had any beef I felt like
MTV coming kept it alive and made it way
worse than it ever would have been I
think it was done right when they
started filming like we got into it and
then made up okay yes
and then that was it and then MTV came
and of course and they came and they
sort of like I mean I don't think we
were like best friends right so we were
like it's fine we never had an issue
with each other
I mean we had an issue with each other
yeah and while they say there wasn't any
real beef between them Lauren admits
that the love triangle portrayed on the
series made for an interesting show
[Music]
um
for the record
[Music]
of course Lauren went on to star in the
spin-off series The Hills
and when ET chatted with her she said
her reality TV days are over to be
honest I just my priorities have changed
you know my family's number one and it
takes a lot to be on reality television
it takes a lot emotionally it's a lot of
time commitment and I did it for a
really long time and I'm so grateful for
my time on television but I'm in a place
now where between my family and my
career like I've got a pretty full plate
so I'm not looking to add anything as
for her time on Laguna Lauren says a lot
of the Shady comments in her narration
came courtesy of production he tried
talking to her at the bonfire I don't
want to talk about it right now I don't
want to talk about that right now but
typical Kristen she just turned and
walked away with Kristen out of the
picture it looked like Steven and I
could hang out again they write you a
script and you're like okay I guess this
is what I read right did you ever push
back I don't think I understood I was
allowed to I would say you know I I
don't think this is right or I feel
uncomfortable but I think because you're
so young and you were like well this is
what I signed up for this is your job
when I got into the hills I pushed back
all the time and Lauren admits she has
one major regret from those on-screen
teen years my biggest regret
I was watching it I I called you a [ __ ]
I know well listen I'm so sorry thank
you it was like thank you she's wearing
a skirt and a little thong and she's up
there like on the pole she knows that's
letting I couldn't believe I did that
because I think where I'm at now like I
would I would never tell another woman
or a girl and it was for me like the
most embarrassing moment I was like oh
gross well thank you I called you a [ __ ]
in a later episode and I also
embarrassed I was gonna apologize to you
I said some really dumb stuff I wasn't
confident at all it was actually so
insecure and so I am sorry for that
because I said some horrible things we
weren't great we were not I'm sorry
and that's what we call squashing the
beef people you know we make do we
figure it out so the big takeaway here
reality TV not always reality so much
fun together yeah I just want everyone
to know we've had a handful of really
great times together
you left yeah yeah exactly yeah
[Music]